Ah !
*souffle*
P'tain mais il est ou ce truc là !
AH !
AAH !
Uh !
Ah, j'ai de l'arthrose !
AH !
Uh !
*(essouflé)*
*(lumière allumée)*
*(musique)*
*(ouverture de porte)*
McCree VS Ange
Quand le mac débarque, c'est la panique au far west
J'suis le king d'Overwatch, personne ne peut me test'
Un poncho bariolé, les poches pleines de billets
Dis-moi sur qui t'as parié, moi j'ai six coups dans le barillets
Face à toi rien à craindre j'ai mis mon gilet pare-balles-tringue
J'te mets du plomb dans l'aile sur un air de piano bastringue
Pull ! C'est le ball-trap
Ooohh !
C'est le ball-trap
Il me suffit d'une balle, pour te faire tomber ma poule
Y a l'bon, la brute, et y'a Jesse McCree
J'tire plus vite que ton ombre et ta tête est mise à prix
Six coups pour six trous de balles, vous êtes tout juste assez
J'le fais à la loyale : « Une dernière volonté ? »
Tu t'prends pour un dalton avec tes bottes et ton Stetson ?
Mais laisse-moi te rappeler que ton nom est personne
À t'écouter rapper, j'ai juste eu mal au crâne
J'vais payer ma tournée, qui veut cent
milligrammes ?
HHAAAN !
J'ai bien compris que t'avais tout piqué à Clint Eastwood
Mais t'as la gueule d'une mascotte d'un mauvais
fast-food
Quand t'essayes de camper, on t'repère à l'odeur
Quand t'essayes de kicker, tu rappes comme un YouTubeur !
HHAAANN !
Tu te prends pour un cow-boy, mais tu s'ras mon cobaye
Tranchant comme un scalpel, mes lyrics sont lethales
Et si tu cries "Medic !", j'temmène aux urgences
Pour mieux te défoncer la gueule, sans ordonnance
Toujours prêts pour le combat
À coups de missiles et de balles et de coups bas
On est la milice ultime, les plus tarés de la team
Les meilleurs ! T'inquiète, on est encore là
(Ça arrive, Ça arrive !)
Toujours prêts pour le combat
À coups de missiles et de balles et de coups bas
On est la milice ultime, les plus tarés de la team
FATAL VS MEI
OK, OK, O-...
Tic-tac c'est la panique, le décompte a
commencé
V'là le dingo, tic-tac, tous les corps vont valdinguer
Mon flow est dé...traqué, et je vais te...traquer
Tu t'es fait a...ttraper, tu vas rester BLOQUÉ (clin d'œil à Orelsan)
Mate ma tactique-tac, j'crame ton anorak
Quand tu vois mon Pneumastic, tu fais dans ton slip,
Tu flippes, tu fuis, t'as l'trac, tu craques, j'te suis à la flaque,
Tu prends tes cliques et tes claques - En un clic je t'éclate
OH !
J'ai pas d'éthique, et j'ai des tocs,
Des rimes en vrac, des mines en stock
Toc toc, qui est là ?
C'est moi !
J'ai mis des grenades dans ton froc
J'envoie ta tête au Mexique
Et tes tripes en Antarctique, tac, boum !
T'es qu'un Joker de pacotille, une pâle copie du Bouffon Vert
Un bouffon... tout court
Mais ferme-là, à quoi tu sers ?
Tu t'es vu avec ta jambe en bois et ton flow en mousse
Je vais t'écraser ta sale face à coups de moon boots
OH !
J'suis pas Schwarzengger mais j'te cryogénise
Ma team crie au génie quand j'te brise le Mister Freeze
Prépare ton testament garçon tu vas mourir tôt
Tu seras pilé en glaçon dans un mojito
*cui cui cui *
Toujours prêts pour le combat
À coups de missiles et de balles et de coups bas
On est la milice ultime, les plus tarés de la team
Les meilleurs ! T'inquiète, on est encore là
(Elle est bientôt prête)
Toujours prêts pour le combat
À coups de missiles et de balles et de coups bas
On est la milice ultime, les plus tarés de la team
Les meilleurs, ah ah, enfin surtout moi
*Incompréhensible*
Quoi ?
Je n'laisse pas de traces, et partout où je passe
Une volée de balles et de coups dans ta face
Personne ne me flash, personne ne me clash
Je trace et même Flash est déjà dépassé
J'ai un coup d'avance, et souvent dans ta gueule
J'ai pas de temps à perdre, je fais cavalier seul
Je remonte le temps jamais à contre-temps
Et c'est tampis pour toi si tu n'as pas le temps
• UN : Je vais te frapper, te saper, te casser, te taper, te killer, te kicker le cul
• Deux : te piler, te flinguer, te fumer, te shooter, te claquer, te cribler de balles
Pan ! Haha, t'es mort mon chou
T'as rappé moins d'une seconde, et j'ai eu le temps d'me faire chier
Si t'aimes bien quand ça va vite, ta mort tu vas l'apprécier
Des flèches dans ta gueule, oh oui ça y'en aura
Mate la fureur du dragon, j'te dis "Sayonara" !
Mes punchlines visent toujours dans le mille, j'suis un expert en balistique
Tu balises quand j'débarque, tes pulseurs, moi j'm'en bats les steaks
Ton temps est compté, ouais gars t'es au courant
Quand t'entends "Ryuu ga waga teki wo kurau"
Même sur une cible en mouvement, le score est sans appel
Je te décroche la pomme d'Adam, plus fort que Guillaume Tell
J'suis pas Cupidon si j'te transperce t'as le coeur brisé
Rien ne sert de courir, suffit d'savoir viser !
MEURS, MEURS, MEURS !
Et voilà !
Y'a quelqu'un ?
Ben ils sont où ?